mesdames et messieurs bonsoir monsieur
le président
bienvenue Bienvenue à tous la Guidel
dont je suis le maire déjà depuis 19 ans
ça ne nous rajeunit pas
et je voulais simplement vous dire que
vous avez pris l'habitude de venir ici à
Belambra et que vous avez fait le bon
choix dans ce domaine aussi
je crois que vous avez un horaire assez
contraint aussi vais-je être bref mais
je vais quand même vous dire deux ou
trois choses sur sur notre ville d'abord
qu'ici alors que vous avez l'impression
d'arriver dans la campagne profonde nous
sommes quand même 10 800 habitants et
que nous avons comme vous l'avez
remarqué c'est pour ça que vous êtes là
quelques avantages à savoir que nous
avons un littoral qui est en grande
partie préservée et où je crois que vous
irez
tâté du pied la température de l'eau de
mer ce soir ou demain matin
l'État
j'interroge le maire de Pontivy qui est
une amie non il n'y a pas la mère à
Pontivy non je me dis on me dit 19
degrés c'est moins dans la baignoire
mais c'est quand même plus que
d'habitude
voilà nous avons une ville
une commune étendue de
5200 hectares ce qui en fait une des
plus grandes du Morbihan et nous avons
surtout un espèce de patchwork assez
assez intéressant vous nous avez nous
avons des zones qui sont évidemment
habitées d'autres sur lesquels on
travaille mais énormément de zones qui
sont des zones tout à fait naturelles
auxquelles nous tenons beaucoup nous
étions il y a pas si longtemps ici 3000
habitants il y a pas si longtemps au
métier peut-être pas nés c'était il y a
40 ans aujourd'hui nous avons donc
multiplié notre la taille de notre
population par deux ou trois plutôt plus
près de 3 que de 2 ce phénomène-là est
un peu en train de se tasser parce que
tout notre pays de l'Orient connaît un
développement
relativement mesuré nous appartenons à
la Communauté d'Agglomération du Pays de
l'Orient qui est dirigé par qui fut
dirigé dans le temps par Jean-Yves Le
Drian qui habite à côté c'est un voisin
et
comment dirais-je et qui aujourd'hui
dirigé par Norbert Métairie son
successeur
nous vivons mal depuis cette année la
nouvelle répartition des pouvoirs dans
les communautés d'agglomération
autrefois il y avait un peu de consensus
tous les présidents étaient vus tous les
tous les maires étaient vice-présidents
ça permettait d'avoir une ambiance
c'était peut-être un peu particulier
mais l'ambiance était au moins assez
amicale aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
dans une situation de majorité
opposition avec des tensions importantes
un peu comme nous pouvons les connaître
dans les conseils municipaux et c'est un
peu dommage que nos élus nationaux et
cru qu'il fallait que les communautés
d'agglomération soient complètement
calqué dans leur fonctionnement sur les
communes
vous savez nous avons un certain nombre
de difficultés nous avons un certain
nombre d'éléments porteurs et qui vont
bien et puis nous avons un certain
nombre de difficultés je vois pas
pourquoi je vous parlerai de ce qui va
bien les trains qui arrivent à l'heure
ça n'intéresse personne tout le monde le
sait je voudrais juste vous parler de ce
qui nous préoccupe en ce moment
je parle à l'ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale la réforme des
rythmes scolaires je ne sais pas si ça
correspondait à une nécessité absolument
urgente et impérative je ne sais pas si
les élèves seront mieux éduqués
que dans le système ancien j'ai des
doutes mais je peux vous dire que mettre
ça en place est un véritable casse-tête
et un casse-tête coûteux le deuxième
essai d'autant plus vrai que la deuxième
difficulté c'est la
la baisse des dotations aux
collectivités locales et
particulièrement aux communes qui va
peser lourdement sur l'investissement
d'autant plus quand nous rajoute des
charges de fonctionnement nouvelles
alors il faudra faire avec mais on s'est
bien qu'aujourd'hui on a du mal on aura
tous du mal à augmenter les impôts
locaux parce que les gens sont saturés
et qu'après tout nous tenons à notre
tête
la troisième difficulté elle est plus
locale c'est celle
de la loi littorale quand on parle de la
loi littorale tout le monde trouve que
c'est formidable et bien
peut-être que François bayroule avait
voté en son temps sûrement sa date de
1984 je crois
la réalité c'est
sauver
autant elle est bonne sur son principe
autant aller infernale dans son
application et je parle au maire de
Pontivy qui était commissaire enquêteur
qui est qui nous a qui a travaillé sur
notre PLU je vais vous donner un exemple
à côté d'ici il y a une commune qui
s'appelle Plouvien pluvien élevé un tout
petit secteur littoral sur la ber wrac
je crois et finalement l'ensemble du
territoire communal était concerné par
la loi littorale et il n'était plus
question d'agrandir une usine qui
voulait s'agrandir qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont cédé la frange littorale à
la commune voisine pour ne plus être
littoral alors quand une loi amène c'est
conséquences là c'est qu'elle est
forcément mal réfléchie il y a un
problème quelque part autant il faut
sauvegarder la frange côtière autant ce
qu'il y a derrière c'est pas le problème
enfin c'est au moins mon opinion
personnelle et puis le quatrième point
sur lequel vous avez dû travailler à
faire mesdames et messieurs dans votre
dans votre université des paix et puis
je m'arrêterai là parce que il faut pas
qu'on soit dépressif non plus nous
avions hier un dépressif qui trouvait
que tout était difficile difficile dur
dur mais nous
nous nous on est plutôt on est plutôt
optimiste de nature quand même mais la
loi srue et la loi du flot maintenant
imaginez-vous qu'ici à Guidel où nous
n'avons aucune industrie vous l'avez vu
nous sommes une ville résidentielle on
va devoir avoir d'après le programme
local de l'habitat du pays de l'Orient
30 % de logements sociaux le préfet m'a
envoyé une lettre aimable il y a
quelques jours et il m'a dit Monsieur
mur vous avez 800 logements sociaux vous
allez devoir en faire 600
supplémentaires d'ici 10 ans on en a 400
font rajouter on en a 400 il faut en
rajouter 600 et en l'espace donc de 10
ans c'est totalement impossible compte
tenu justement de la loi littorale qui
limite les zones constructives mais
c'est aussi
idiot puisque nous avons une centaine de
demandes voilà donc dans si un jour vous
devez voter des lois n'oubliez pas
que la loi n'est pas la même partout
pareil de façon stupide dogmatique nous
sommes
j'exagère il faut que je m'en aille nous
dans un régime dogmatique
qui considère que tous doivent être
traités de la même façon évidemment pas
voilà je vous invite à travailler sur ce
thème et je vous remercie d'être venu à
Guidel